All right. Microchipping Oh God. Don't even get me started on this.
I, I just cannot fucking, but like,
I just can't fucking believe this shit.
Do you know Delta Airlines wants to start using people's fingerprints?
It's a way for you to get on the fucking plane and do you know that most people
won't have a problem with it? They're so fucking stupid.
It's like there's so many people out in the world. It's almost like,
you know what too? Why don't you just become a fucking slave?
Like how much you're going to give to these people.
How underpaid are politicians that they will not stand up to these people,
these corporations, I swear to God,
they sitting there wasting all this fucking time with Isis and all this other
bullshit, these fucking corporations, the,
the shit that they're doing to their own goddamn country man,
which they really don't have because they're fucking global.
They don't give a shit about anything about just trying to make more fucking
money and they want, they going to start microchip and people.
It's Wisconsin, Wisconsin Company, two implant, Mike, Implant microchips, uh,
employees in like, like five people already agreed to it.
They're going to take something foreign that's not natural to your body,
and they're going to stick it underneath your fucking skin.
They're going to know where you are at all fucking times and all these fucking
dope player, you know, [inaudible] we keep the problem.
Here's the fucking problem. Okay?
Just because you're a fucking dope doesn't mean the rest of the world is okay.
I think it's safe to say that me and everybody else listening to this thing,
for the most part was not as smart. It's fucking George Washington. Right?
Fair enough. Okay, well, here's the deal.
If George Washington was microchipped and all his fucking buddies were
microchipped,
his fucking country wouldn't exist cause they would've known where he was.
They would've gone over there and they would have fucking killed him.
And that would have been the end of the fucking rebellion.
So what you're doing is,
is you're having faith that these fucking people at the top who have not even
remotely demonstrated on any fucking level at any point in history,
that they give a flying fuck about anybody other than themselves are going to,
you're going to turn over that level of power.
You're going to get fingerprinted by Delta fucking airlines,
like you've committed some sort of a fucking crime.
If fucking airline is going to have your fucking fingerprints,
who in the fuck did they think they are? Do you know what? I went to buy my car.
They asked for my thumbprint. I was like,
I'm not getting my fucking fingerprints to your car dealership. They go, well,
this is to protect you. No, it isn't yet douche.
You're going to sell this to somebody. It's part of my profile.
I think they just, they're collecting,
they're all sharing information about you, what you buy, where you live,
what your social security number is.
You fucking fingerprints are going to get it all the way down to your fucking
DNA. It's an it's, I dunno.
Yeah.
And these politicians will not push back on any level because the president
makes 500 grand a year.
That's the highest paid political office is 500 fucking grand a year and they
need $100 million to get the job. I don't have 100 million.
You don't have 100 million corporations do. And that's who they owe it to.
So they just look the other fucking way. And what do they do?
They sit there and they shit on fucking comedians constantly going after.
Do you hear what he said about Caitlyn Jenner?
And they look the other way with pharmaceutical companies handing out fucking
opiates.
Like they've given out flyers to some sort of jam band and now we've got this
heroin fucking prom. They don't give a fuck. They don't say anything about it.
Sorry, I know I'm fucking losing my shit here. But like,
okay,
what they've done to the food supply, what the fuck they they,
the what the bankers have done left all these people upside down in their own
fucking houses. What they've done to the water supply,
fracking causing earthquakes in parts of the world that never had fucking
earthquakes. Fucking up the drinking water.
Okay.
You know,
they've got to send a fucking pipeline under the fucking native Americans land.
I mean, like, like we haven't done enough to those fucking people,
you know? Do you hear any politicians talking about that now?
Nobody talks about that shit, but God for fucking bid,
you do a fucking joke in a strip mall and it fucking all over it.
Then that becomes like some big goddamn story. Um,
this is fucking horrific and it makes me happy that I'm 49 years of age.
The fact that I think I'm going to maybe get to live half a fucking century
without a fucking airline having my fingerprints and me walking around with the
goddamn microchip. You know, I love that.
I lived 50 years before the fucking oh Jesus. She's up. Huh.
Um, I love that. And that got to live 50 years before robots showed up.
Um, it's just,
it's just greed and power completely.
100% out of control.
And I hate like this is, I'm reading this,
this is eye witness ABC News.
So these guys are all bought and paid for CNN bought and paid for Fox News is
bought and paypal,
they're all fucking bought and paid for because the same people I just brought
brought up,
they advertise on their fucking networks so they have to watch what they say
because they don't want to lose the ad money cause that's how they get paid,
right. So they always have like the, oh Geez, this is a little unsettling.
You know when they always come back from it, when they show some fucking robot,
you've ever seen that? You watched it? The local news or what?
They show somebody getting microchip and they always come back to the anchors
and they kind of do that. Ooh, that's kind of a,
and then they just move on to the next thing.
But some fucking old lady who makes her own jam,
like that's supposed to make you feel better at the end of the fucking newscast
or some puppy that they thought was lost and fucking sniffed its way back to the
station wagon. Three towns away, right?
Whenever the fuck leave you on [inaudible]
um,
now corporations are completely out of control.
They've been out of control my entire life and now it's,
it's reaching a level that it's like you're watching a bad scifi movie.
I think it's fucking insane. Why?
Why the fuck do you need my fingerprints as a fucking airline?
Who the fuck are you? You're not the FBI. You're not the government.
You're a fucking airline.
Your fingerprints, and this is the thing people will do.
People will fucking do all of this so they don't have to stand in a line
bill. Let them scan their fucking retina.
They'll give him a fucking baby just so they can be pre-checked that's all you
got to do.
You just hold a little cookie out and the average fucking mouth breathe in
fucking Maura. But you know something, I got to swear to God. I mean,
this is really cynical, but I,
you walk around and I finally got half the fucking people should be
microchipped. You should know where these fucking idiots are.
Okay?
Yeah.
I'll never forget that guy gallop in sideways on that Trump rally screaming at
all these stupid liberals going, fuck political correctness. Build the wall.
Build the wall is he's fucking galloping. Like, like,
that was gonna make his life better.
Like that was what was holding him back. I swear to God,
like,
I don't give a fuck how dumb you are. You have to know as a white dude,
if you were born in the United States of America, okay,
you're not going to get a better starting block than that.
All right? And if you can't figure out some sort of gay, I mean,
if you're going to fucking blame anybody, why are you going to look down?
You've got to go up. That's what's fucking you over.
Democrats and Republicans fucking you over.
I just don't get how people don't see that. Um, but I'm like, most people,
I feel like my ideas are right and no one else has a good point.
Um,
unreal, this fucking car dealership. Can we get your thumbprint? It's like,
yeah, no, you guys sell cars.
Do you understand that you guys lie for a living?
Other salesman who lie for a living turn the other way.
You let you turn the other way. When they see a car salesman, you like the head,
you like the bottom of the barrel fucking salesman.
I'm going to give you my fingerprint.
You know why they said they wanted my fingerprint?
They go just in case somebody comes in and tries to
is an impostor and pretends that they're you and tries to buy a car.
And I just looked at the guy and I was like, you know what?
I'm going to take my chances on that.
The guy literally goes
in, this is what killed me. He goes,
you're the first person we've ever have say no to that.
Now I hope he's just being a car salesman.
And he was lying to me and that was his last ditch effort to try to convince me.
Um,
but uh, the other part is actually telling the truth. It's just like,
then what happens is what, what,
this is how they do it is most people are adults.
So they don't think,
and then what happens is it becomes a herd mentality and all they gotta do is
get most of the herd to start running over the fucking cliff. And you,
you have to do it too. Cause if you don't,
then you're just gonna be fucking sitting there all by yourself. Like, Hey,
I'm not gonna have a cell phone. Hey, I'm not going to have this.
I'm not going to have that. And then your life,
the way you're going to lead it becomes extremely limited.
And next thing you know,
you're fucking half naked walking around your backyard trying to like trap
squirrels,
seek and eat that day because you're not doing what everybody else is doing.
Um,
it's just, you know, it's going to be the worst is when they try to convince,
uh,
when they tried to convince people to do it right.
There's going to be some politician getting it with that fucking smile on his
face, where he's like, I don't want to do this, but I have to do this.
I have to do this so I can go on the post president fucking,
you know,
$70 million speaking tour where I go out and I give speeches to the same fucking
people that put me into office, like the hero of all hero presidents.
Obama is about to do. He just,
he has that motherfucker has $69 million with the gigs on the books coming up.
You know, I will never, for the life of me understand why that guy,
people look like liberals.
Look at that guy like he fucking did something for him. I will never get that.
It's like that guy had his face in the pig trough just like everybody else.
I mean, I don't know. I don't know what it is.
I think it's because he's sandwiched between two of the worst public speakers of
all time, Bush and fucking Trump. You know what I mean?
I think if he came after Clinton where Clinton wasn't the greatest, Whoa, whoa,
whoa, Whoa, whoa. But he got enough. The women fucking loved them.
I will never get that either. How much women love that fucking big fucking baby?
He, we look at goofball. Um, Jesus Bell.
There are any presidents that you liked? Yeah, I lied in mind.
The first George Bush fucking war hero and I liked, uh,
I liked Jimmy Carter.